[Music]
this is the singer 21c
it's yet another hypercar what they
promise 0-60 time of 1.9 seconds but as
crazy as it is to say that's not a
special part of this car
[Music]
the unique part is that the 21 C's frame
is made up of a lattice of 3d printed
aluminum notes connected together with
carbon-fiber poles these nodes are
printed by firing a laser onto a bed of
fine aluminum powder to print a layer of
the node once the layer is complete more
powder is pushed on top of that printed
layer and the process repeats until you
get the finished products
but the 21c represents more than just a
cold 3d printed projects it represents
the slow but sure shift from the
bottlenecks of traditional manufacturing
to digitizing manufacturing into
software it represents turning billions
of dollars and years of development to
makin new products and to maybe a few
million dollars in a few weeks it
represents saving more lives from the
global shortage of organ transplants by
just printing more organs it represents
the starts of the 3d printing industrial
revolution so we're right at the
beginning of a revolution yeah this is a
this is a fourth Industrial Revolution
in the making it's both better cheaper
faster it's gonna actually evolve more
quickly than other technologies our
printing technology has surpassed even
where sci-fi has put some in some parts
of technology which is often surprising
to see videos like this take a lot of
time and energy to make that's why I
really appreciate sponsors like
Skillshare the first 500 people who
click the link in the description we get
to three months of Skillshare premium
with access to over 25,000 classes and
business entrepreneurship and tech check
it out with the link below meet
Relativity co-founded by previous SpaceX
and Blue Origin employees they're
working on bringing the power of 3d
printing to disrupt 60 years of
aerospace engineering now claiming to
disrupt an industry is about as cliche
as it gets for startups these days but
relativity is pretty promising backed by
big investors like Mark Cuban Y
Combinator and partnered with giants
like the US Air Force and NASA they've
created the world's largest 3d printer
with the aim of churning out shiny new
rockets in as little as 60 days
compare that to SpaceX Falcon 9 which
takes around 18 months to build or up to
5 years for something more complex like
the Space Shuttle normally I get in a
tank
of this size in like aerospace or rocket
quality would take you well over 12
months how long did it take you to make
this it's like seven days a friend times
actually the cabinet's developed and
seven days this is done by automating
the entire process we have a patent that
covers the real-time controls during the
printing process and that patent covers
novel techniques for applying machine
learning and AI compared to other
methods of 3d printing metal like the
one we saw the hypercar use which
relativity does use for smaller parts of
the rocket instead of laying out a bed
of metal powder relativity retrofitted a
giant robot arm to feed in aluminum wire
melt it on the spot with a powerful
laser imagine it kind of like forming a
clay bowl on a wheel but instead of clay
it's metal and instead of placing clay
onto the wheel first and then working it
with your hands the printer lays down a
meadow as the base spins slowly forming
different sections of the rocket not
only is this process faster with
different rocket sections being able to
be printed in parallel but one of the
biggest advantages is flexibility then
that traditionally factories are made of
tons of fixed tooling then very
expensive very hard to change then where
you have to retool a factory in order to
make a new product or even change the
product slightly for us we can change
all of that in software so it's
digitizing the manufacturing process and
fried enough flexibility where if you
push new code to the printers and the
hardware on the factory for you can
actually make an entirely different
product without changing anything in
hardware since you can 3d print complex
shapes all at once relativity has been
able to cut down on a number of
different parts and a rocket by upwards
of a hundred times and like any product
the less parts there are the less things
can break that's how they're able to
manufacture an entire rocket engine that
only has three parts in nine days and
what's all these advantages coming
together into one they have the long
term goal of sending these printers up
onto a rocket
sending it off to Mars to build rockets
on Mars that way astronauts that land on
Mars have another way to get home easier
relativity are far from the only ones to
have thought of the potential for 3d
printing in aerospace which has been
around for a few years now
has already integrated 3d printing into
the Dragon spacecraft made to carry
humans they've done this in the crafts
emergency escape system which is powered
by their superdraco engines in which the
combustion chambers are fully 3d printed
another startup called launcher have
also joined the party with a focus in
helping the small satellite market
launch more affordably with their 3d
printed copper rocket engines but unlike
their competitors relativity is the only
company with the goal of a near 100% 3d
printed rocket aimed for launch in 2021
time will tell but one thing's for sure
the space industry is a fascinating age
[Music]
aside from the faraway frontier of space
back in Tabasco Mexico 3d printing is
hitting a little closer to home
Tabasco is home to some of the lowest
income families in Mexico with
seventy-six dollars and fifty cents per
month or less than three dollars a day
as the median income with a good chunk
of them living in makeshift unsafe
shelter this is the site that the
startup icon chose to create the world's
first 3d printed housing community to
support the families living in extreme
poverty thanks to their new volcan to
concrete home printer they're able to
provide these people with five hundred
square foot homes featuring two beds a
living room kitchen and bath while being
stronger and more resilient than
traditionally built homes that can
withstand the earthquakes in the region
because you know it's concrete and each
of these homes were built in just around
24 hours of total print time spread out
over a few days we've been able to do is
create something that you just sent up
once on a foundation you have you know -
our magma system this is our material
delivery system that we've built
in-house and then you're off to the
races
their latest update was back in the
summer with 2l 250 homes already built
this Mexico project was as difficult as
you can possibly imagine
it's a seismic zone it's extremely
remote power cuts out from time to time
there are safety concerns you know in
this part of Mexico I was just not very
safe sometimes you put all that together
and it's just like an enormous challenge
not just from a technology perspective
just operationally the core of what
makes this possible is the printer in
their proprietary concrete mix the
printer itself can build up to 2,000
square feet in virtually any for plan
faster with less waste at around half of
the cost of traditional home building if
you ever see normal concrete poured it
kind of just flows over like a thicker
liquid which wouldn't really work in an
application like this so they've had to
create a new mix from scratch that's
able to keep its form while printing at
high speeds providing enough strength
and insulation and that can be made with
raw materials available around the world
and thanks to lists they're able to
replace all the traditional wood
insulation and drywall in one fell swoop
and of course everything is controlled
from a tablet icons 3d printed homes
aren't
for people living in absolute poverty
though they're working on a housing
community in Austin Texas as we speak
they've got a few partnerships right now
and apparently many more in the pipeline
so maybe in the future the next home you
buy might be a 3d printed one wonder of
the limits of mechanical engineering is
that we're limited by what our tools can
make especially when it comes to dealing
with metal so instead of manufacturing
following design it's design following
behind what manufacturing can do
although were far from getting rid of
that limitation altogether even what 3d
printing a company called just hop
meadow is taking a step in the right
direction tools are fairly difficult to
use to create very very complex shapes
but with additive manufacturing of metal
we can create crazy shapes they've
created a software that uses algorithms
to generate the most efficient strongest
design using the least amount of
material designs that would be too
difficult to make with traditional tools
but it's just another day in the life of
a 3d printer so what we're doing is
we're sort of subjecting these parts to
this washing machine effect of dynamic
transitional horses so what we have is
the ability to very quickly create
shapes that are very strong and
lightweight where basically the cell
mass is distributed only where it's
needed
yet another example of 3d printing
bringing the world of software and
hardware a little closer together it's
not like you tell a computer make it I
inspired shape is that you tell a
computer give me the most efficient
shape and the shape that you're getting
looks bio
[Music]
3d printing has been around for a few
decades now but it's only really started
making its way to the mainstream back in
2009 when a few key patents started to
expire which paved the way for huge
price drops and improvements in the
technology but the biggest thing holding
3d printing back is still cost with
traditional mass production as you
produce more goods the cost continues to
drop also known as the economies of
scale but with 3d printing as you print
more copies the price doesn't go down
enough to justify completely replacing
mass production along with the other
limitations of 3d printing that the
strength of these printed parts
that's why leading up to now 3d printing
has only been used for what it was best
for prototyping new designs extremely
fast but the CEO of desktop meadow
thinks that that age has already started
coming to an end and three degree to the
first 20 years was used for prototyping
and now we're going into a new phase of
3d printing where we we go from
prototyping into mass production and
that has huge implications if we can
reduce the raw material cost with better
supply and decrease 3d printer machine
costs we can lower this line and open up
more parts to being replaced by 3d
printing and as we've seen in this video
3d printing has already moved its way
into huge areas of humanity and it's
only gonna go up from here
if there's one thing we can agree on and
take away from these videos it's this
the world is moving really fast and in
many different directions in 3d printing
alone we just covered three different
movements happening in the space with
many more that I didn't even have time
to cover and asked the famous business
theorist re the goose pizza the ability
to learn faster than your competitors
may be the only sustainable competitive
advantage which basically means that if
you're not learning fast and allots
you're not gonna last
that's why I love sponsors like
Skillshare because not only do they make
these videos easier for me to make but
they allow people like you to learn more
of what you're interested in faster on
your own time so you don't just survive
in this fast-paced world but you thrive
if you don't know what's kosher is it's
an online learning community where for
less than $10 a month you get access to
over 25,000 classes from experts and
creators on every topic you can think of
including business entrepreneurship
coding and much more and the first 500
people who click the link in the
description we get to three months of
Skillshare premium with access to all
these classes so that you can start
building up your repertoire of skills to
thrive in all these new waves happening
right now
just like 3d printing so check it out
with the link below you have nothing to
lose and everything to gain and you get
to support the brands that helped make
this channel possible
welcome to the Wachtler n club and if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
see more videos just like this one I
make video essays just like this on the
most interesting and like provocative
stuff in the world of business every
single week for your viewing pleasure so
please consider clicking that red
subscribe button below along with the
bell icon right next to it because the
channel is growing pretty fast and you
get to be a part of the first 100,000
subscribers but the prize being my
appreciation and more free videos if you
want to support this channel financially
check out Skillshare it's a winner for
you and it's a win for me and it's one
for Skillshare so everyone wins you can
follow me on instagram at jake trend
ahhhh i oh that is gonna be enough
shameless plug for this video you've
been awesome
I've been Jake I'll see you guys in the
next one
[Music]